[Musique]
bonsoir mais fier petit ami vraiment il
commence à faire froid dans le ciel
alors nounours tu descends à voir
nicolas et pimprenelle weepu retrouve
une moto pompe pompe
je t'ai bien entendu la musique de tout
ça j'ai foi qu'est ce qu'il ya pas bonne
elle tu veux mon petit nicolas qui
votent enrhumé si tu mets le nez dehors
sans te couvrir enfants second front bon
dieu va faire entrer vite petit facteur
un buffet froid la plaque courrier pour
cette maison là dedans elle est à moi
cette casquette comme en mode moiselle
pas prodl c'est parfait
[Musique]
nounours nicolas et pimprenelle à celle
là elle est pour moi
puis un beau du sein dont regarder mais
c'est moi je suis très bien il est très
réussie ce dessin maman dit il ne faut
pas sucer son pouce
elle a donné raison à un moment mon
petit pierrot regard moment la belle
carte en colère qui a nourri mon petit
frère et moi on est très sage et on se
couche quand tu dis bonne nuit à nicolas
et la pape rhône elle que ce genre
petit louisette je t'envoie deux gros
baiser un portois rapportons petit frère
regard aucun drôle de l'être montrez moi
ça
voyons voir c'est curieux c'est sûrement
pour le marchand de sable
je vais l'aliment autres et tu restes il
est tard à long ou doudounes les petits
tient pas tant courrier annonce bien sûr
on va se coucher tout seuls comme des
grands
et demain on verra les autres à l'être
on revoir mes petits achats n'annonce
pas de nuit ni
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
mais oui mes petits amis
il est tard il faut vite aller vous
coucher
me voilà pas trop j'apporte du courrier
pour vous une fenêtre bizarre mais c'est
un timbre chinois car dès le moi pour ma
collection patron voyant cher marchand
de sable et cher gros nounours
il faut absolument que vous veniez
endormir les petits chinois
ils vous attendent on compte sur vous
mille gros baiser signé king fu
c'est un petit gars jouent je crois bien
qu'oui ce serait très gentil d'aller les
voir plus selon lui du cadre aurait
voyage bras de toute façon du colloque
un panel sont rares eh bien nous allons
préparer nos bagages tous nos amis
seront enchantés que nous allions voir
d'autres enfants et nous aurons des tas
d'histoires nouvelle à le raconter
bonne nuit les petits à dimanche
nous viendrons vous dire au revoir aux
bimbos
[Musique]
oh